what a relief that you're in this kind
of a good mood thank you because it is
Friday the 13th and yes and if you're
worried about Black Cats head over to
the SAE fraternity at Oklahoma
University because there's no black cats
there oh you heard you saw that story
breaking news frat guys are huge
[ __ ] I mean if you missed this story
yes at this fraternity chapter at the
Oklahoma University the SAE chapter
apparently it's like this you know in
some other places but I guess this is
the worst and they were chanting on a
bus something I guess they've been
passed down to this fried for decades
and I won't disgust you with what the
chant was but the basic idea of it was
they were congratulating themselves that
there would never be a black person at
their fraternity and all the black
people on canvas were like like any of
us would ever want to join your Dockers
wearing frisbee golfing corny cracker
ass fraternity to begin with now another
racist news over in Ferguson Missouri
the police chief there did resign and
and then they had a big protest see this
is what I understand you get what you
want and then you protest what do we
want justice when did we get it
yesterday and of course when you need to
come racial tensions in America who
better to start talking about it then
Rudy Giuliani Rudy Giuliani was out
there today I mean I I cannot make this
[ __ ] up he says that Obama is talking to
black people all wrong cuz of course who
would know better have to talk to black
people Obama or Rudy Giuliani can't make
this up Rudy says Obama should talk to
black people more like the way Bill
Cosby does only Rudy could see a serial
rapist and go yes look one of the good
ones you can
we can read all about it in Rudy's new
book the official creeps guide to other
creeps but good news ladies and
gentlemen the Republican Party has a new
star he's Tom cotton the 37 year old
Republican senator from Arkansas now as
you probably know the Obama
administration have been working for
years on a nuclear deal with Iran we
would lift the sanctions they would not
develop their nuclear program well Tom
cotton wrote a letter to Iran signed by
47 Republican senators which basically
said don't bother making a deal with our
government and Obama because when he's
gone we'll just cancel it
real mature and on the second page it
was just a picture of Obama they drew
dicks on
and of course Iran's reaction was rather
Swift they said Republicans are behaving
in a way that is not only rude but
condescending and stupid hey mullahs
welcome to our world
oh and speaking of stupid email gate has
entered its second week did you see
Hillary's press conference this week oh
it was she was defending her use of
private using a private email account
and it was riveting television if you
consider someone in a pantsuit talking
about serving servers for an hour to be
riveting television you know it's not
really that complicated Hillary said yes
look looking back I should have probably
used to email accounts or to servers
whatever one official and one for
private but I just wound up using one
out of convenience same reason I stay
married
it's a typical typical Clinton scandal
right stage one they broke a rule nobody
ever heard of that isn't exactly kosher
but it doesn't really affect anybody's
life stage two Republicans say that this
rule was the keystone to our entire way
of life and if we let it go Mount
Rushmore will explode and our guns will
melt in our hands stage three nothing
happens I want to ask them what do they
think they are going to find in
Hillary's email she's the most boring
person in the world do they really think
they're gonna find one that says I hate
America and love scissoring and if they
did what would happen they meanwhile our
state of California today announced that
we have as of today one year of water
left
so let's definitely keep obsessing about
emails because it's only [ __ ] water
ladies and gentlemen who cares about
water Apple it's making a new watch are
you gonna line up with yes the I watch
this is amazing technology listen but
you know the clock on your phone they
found a way to shrink it and put it on
your wrist it is a wondrous time to be
alive
this device is so amazing it will remind
you to make phone calls it will track
your calories it will tell you when you
need to exercise it's like having a tiny
Jewish mother strapped to your wrist